Speaker 1: So we had some
major media news yesterday,
many of you emailing me about it, tweeting to
me about it, sending me very, very respectful
Speaker 2: of sorts
Speaker 1: of messages
about it. The story is Chris Wallace leaving
Fox News and joining CNN plus CNN Plus being
a new streaming service from CNN. And this
is a really big deal in the political media
space because Chris Wallace, as many of you
know, was one of what we would call the lone
occasional voices of reason on Fox News, which
was basically a sea of propaganda. And I've
had a number of different thoughts about Chris
Wallace presence on Fox in the past, which
there's no better time to talk about that now. But
let's first take a look at Chris Wallace making
the announcement yesterday on Fox News Sunday
Speaker 3: after 18 years. This is my final Fox
News Sunday. It is the last time and I say this
with real sadness we will meet like this. Eighteen
years ago, the bosses here at Fox promised me they
would never interfere with a guest I booked or a
question I asked. And they kept that promise. I
have been free to report to the best of my ability
to cover the stories I think are important
to hold our country's leaders to account.
It's been a great ride. We've
covered five presidential elections,
interviewed every president since George H.W. Bush
traveled the world, sitting down with France's
Emmanuel Macron and Russia's Vladimir Putin. And
I've gotten to spend Sunday mornings with you.
It may sound corny, but I feel we built a
community here. There's a lot you can do
on Sunday mornings. The fact you've chosen to
spend this hour with us is something I cherish.
But after 18 years, I have decided to leave Fox.
I want to try something new to go beyond politics
to all the things I'm interested in. I'm ready
for a new adventure and I hope you'll check
it out. And so for the last time, dear friends.
Speaker 1: OK, so he's leaving. He said he has new
projects, and then within two hours, CNN announced
he's going to be joining as an anchor of their new
streaming service. CNN Plus, which
doesn't exist yet, it's expected to debut
Speaker 2: early next year.
Speaker 1: So is this good or is this bad? And for
Speaker 2: who or whom, depending on
Speaker 1: your preference?
Speaker 2: On the one hand, it's been clear
Speaker 1: for a long time
that Chris Wallace Days Fox were
probably numbered if he was going to keep
Speaker 2: asking just
Speaker 1: real
Speaker 2: questions of Republicans.
Speaker 1: When Republicans would be on
and we had all of these different examples of
I don't even remember what Senator it was, who
was talking about debt. And Chris Wallace pointed
out, well, a lot of that debt accrued under Trump,
not under Joe Biden. And you know, this is
flexing in other countries. We would call it basic
journalism. It was rare on Fox and because Chris
Wallace was doing it and he was doing it with the
Republicans as well as Democrats. It was rare it
stood out and there was some sense that at some
Speaker 2: point he might be gone.
Speaker 1: Now, on the one hand,
you could say his mere presence on Fox was a
net positive because there were some viewers
who were fully accepting all the propaganda.
Speaker 2: And even if they
didn't care that this is what
Speaker 1: Chris Wallace was doing,
they would be exposed to it for a moment.
And maybe he would change some minds and
get some of these mindless Fox viewers to
think, Hey, here's another perspective.
The counterpoint to that is that Chris
Wallace did provide Fox News cover
Speaker 2: in a major way to be able
Speaker 1: to say,
We're fair and balanced. We have
Speaker 2: news and we have
Speaker 1: opinion. That's one they've been
hiding behind for a very long time. It's like,
yes, you have news and opinion. It's blurred.
And even the news sounds like opinion.
Speaker 2: And we have plenty of people
Speaker 1: holding Republicans
Speaker 2: accountable, like Chris Wallace.
Speaker 1: They used to have Shep Smith, although
Shep Smith left, and in that sense, it provided
Speaker 2: cover for Fox
Speaker 1: News to be marginally more plausible
Speaker 2: as an actual news channel
Speaker 1: of sorts, with actual journalism
being done. And so with Chris Wallace leaving,
Speaker 2: does it
Speaker 1: prevent Fox from now
Speaker 2: having that cover?
Speaker 1: My bottom line on this is as follows I
Speaker 2: think it's a you've got two sides of
Speaker 1: the scale and they're they're really
both doing work. It's close, right? On the one
hand, his presence is good as an alternative to
the propaganda. On the other hand, his presence
allows Fox to run interference. My expectation
is that now Chris Wallace will be replaced
with a total Partizan hack. People on Twitter,
we're talking about Dana Perino. Dana Perino,
who's a Fox anchor now, was George W. Bush's press
secretary, Robin. Give me a break, guys.
Speaker 2: So he'll probably
Speaker 1: be replaced with someone
Speaker 2: much worse.
Speaker 1: I think that by a small
margin, small margin. Wallace on Fox
was a net positive. He did ask real questions
and maybe convinced some people. He did
Speaker 2: allow Fox to say, We have a
Speaker 1: variety and we have journalism
and we have Chris Wallace. I think the the benefit
of having him there slightly slightly outweighed
the very pernicious reality that he was running
interference for what was otherwise a complete
and total propaganda media outlet.
Speaker 2: And in
Speaker 1: particular, if he now gets replaced
Speaker 2: with Tucker or Hannity wannabe
Speaker 1: not not literally
Tucker, but a Tucker or Hannity
Speaker 2: Tucker or Hannity
Speaker 1: wannabe. I think we are worse off.
Speaker 2: And so the
Speaker 1: criticism that he ran interference
for a horrible propaganda network is 100 percent
accurate. And I would say by like five percent
him being there was a net benefit. Do you
disagree with me? I want to hear from him